did the weekend ever consider being
Salinas kidney donor we got some new
info plus Taylor Swift goes back to her
country roots while Justin Timberlake
and LeBron James pull off a big surprise
of their own hey guys this is the daily
Denney we're kicking off Monday stories
with a follow up to all the buzz
surrounding the weekend's new music
which as we told you guys on Friday
seemed to take aim at ex Selena Gomez
and it was this pointed lyric that had
many thinking the weekend almost donated
a kidney to Selena
while they were dating
[Music]
some suggested this was a direct
reference to Selena's kidney transplant
which happened just a few months before
they broke up while today a source tells
ET that's not the case it's just a lyric
that he knew would strum up attention
and that people would interpret it
exactly as they have but he was never
actually going to donate his kidney to
Selena the source at Selena would have
never even asked him her close friend
actress francia raisa ended up donating
a kidney to her last summer and our
source says it was difficult enough for
Selena to allow her lifelong friend to
do it but a new boyfriend no way and get
this according to the source Selena in
the weekends 10 month relationship was
not as serious or intense as his new
music suggests quote the weekend was
always much more concerned with his
career than his relationship
Selena leaned on friends and family
during the surgery more than anyone this
might explain why he qu ran back to the
Biebs what do you guys think are you
surprised by all this and that things
between the weekend and Selena went down
like it did why would you guys sit on
that but you know speaking of surprises
some very lucky fans in Nashville got
this surprise t-swift show
supercool considering Taylor is about to
start her reputation stadium tour which
means she will play the crowds ranging
from oh just a small sixty to a hundred
thousand fans a night but over the
weekend Taytay played to some forty
amazed patrons at the Bluebird Cafe the
first time she played there she was only
14 and this time whiskey shots were
involved there was a totally unannounced
show with friend and songwriter Craig
Weissman where Taylor returned to her
country roots to perform little big
town's better man which she of course
wrote for the band take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
meanwhile in front of thousands Justin
Timberlake had a bit of a bromance
surprise in Cleveland none other than
King James himself LeBron James joined
JT on stage with shots once again this
time for him and his crew
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that tour of Justin's has been pretty
boozy am i right all right he said he
had no idea LeBron would pop up on stage
but it might be something they cooked up
the night before during LeBrons game in
the very same arena LeBron was feeling
the love and shared this shot from one
veteran to another quote one of the
greatest to ever do it in my lifetime
and still going strong
don't stop bro you know there's nothing
like sports legends paying respect to
music legends you guys will remember
Laker icon Kobe Bryant surprised Taylor
Swift during her sold-out show at the
Staples Center yep the same arena Kobe
played in with this banner in honor of
our 16th sold-out show at Staples the
most of any other artist
[Applause]
so here's a question which duo would you
want to have dinner with Justin and
LeBron or Taylor and Kobe and speaking
of Kobe where's the beef that's right I
did it
I finished my 21-day vegan diet I still
don't look like Beyonce but you know we
tried it anyways thanks for watching
guys I'm hungry
gonna go find some beef maybe hamburger
see you guys tomorrow
[Music]